um okay so I have a question
going back to like the father's thing
why is it when would you guys agree that
if a father abandons his child he's a
deadbeat
is incompetent man yeah like yeah just
yes or no yes yeah yeah just like
overall yeah okay why is it when a woman
aborts her child they call it her choice
oh yeah that's that's a living modern
day double standard because she's just
as bad she's worse in my eyes I mean
I've got my opinion on that but yeah my
body my choice in it yeah yeah but why
she's a bolt in it but all based on
circumstances
well I mean 40 of women that have had
abortions have had two or more so I
can't seems like it's a pattern at some
point what if the woman doesn't want the
man around
I I feel that like I feel like I
shouldn't I shouldn't have to pay if you
don't want me around the kid
fair enough don't don't make me pay for
it then if you want a kid without a
father and you don't want me around like
why am I responsible for anything
and and if if I have to be responsible
I want to have equal equal access to the
child right yeah it's just like the
example of my my friend that I said
previously he didn't want it she did
she went along with it had it
and in the night he tried to deny his
access financially to it only for her to
leave the country and come back and try
claim of him now he wanted to be
involved
wasn't allowed not because he not
because of any other reason other than
the poisoning of the mother to the child
and now the child because he's our
Liberty to speak to the child but the
child doesn't want to do you know what
that is
you see because men will act actions we
will react straight away but females are
vengeful they'll remember so she's doing
this so he squeals are you saying so are
you saying are you saying we hold
grudges
so now he feels insignificant at being a
man she knows how he feels and she knows
it and she's doing no purpose she's
watching him cry inside then she's happy
that's evil so do you think mothers get
too much power when it comes to children
that's evil 100 no no no mothers should
have that power I feel that fathers
don't get enough power
because we want to be equal so we don't
need to remove rights from a certain
from a certain gender to have equal
rights we need we just need to give more
rights to the opposite one like we need
to eliminate double standards but we can
only do that together women have to be
on board with this if women say I don't
need a man and they have a kid does that
imply that the kid doesn't need a father
essentially essentially yeah in their
mind essentially I mean it the stats
don't add up not only that biologically
you don't know it don't make sense you
have a masculine and feminine role for a
reason
would you say that
by that we can say that single mothers
are selfish
he chose violence I feel like you're
saying single mothers but you've got to
understand why the woman is single in
the first place if the man has decided
to leave that was his choice no that's
not true man don't leave women women
leave 70 to 80 percent of the time 90 of
their college is it due to the men's
actions to why they're black for example
I mean cheated uh cheating cheating is
similar rates and and so there's some
recent studies that say that women cheat
more but is that the reason why the
women are leaving these men no but like
you know what's funny though why is it
in this in this situation you're asking
why but when the man leaves no one asks
why people do ask why the man leaves why
is the man leaving and they're less
likely to watch I mean when I just asked
everyone is it a deadbeat nobody said
well yeah they're more likely exercises
no way I didn't I didn't agree with that
wait I agree with a statement but the
same way if a Mom leaves she's also a
deadbeat because why are you not looking
after your kid if you've taken the
responsibility to get someone pregnant
have a child and bring that child to
full time where it's going to be
delivered both of you should be having
that responsibility to now raise that
child that is your individual
responsibility to take listen don't
leave their bought listen to what you
said both of them have to have their
responsibility so if the mother leaves
or the father leaves somehow they're
both at fault but they're not they're
not leaving they're reporting oh wait
they're just they're just negating
responsibility in toll I feel like but
that's different because with an
abortion and if the mother chooses
pro-choice she wants to get rid of the
the fetus it's not it's it's not it's
not it doesn't have a
it's not viable on its own essentially
it hasn't been born it hasn't been
birthed it's not viable it actually it
actually is in the UK so in the United
States yeah in the UK it's legal up to
six months and there are some there are
some babies that have survived survived
around five I have a solution so you've
got sorry so you don't think that
it's a child or it's actually a human
being before 24 weeks you don't think
that's a human being it's It's Not a
Human Being before 24 weeks but if you
decide to leave a child that's an that's
a whole formed entity that can exist on
its own do you go what I'm saying this
on their own for for a woman to have an
abortion pro-choice it's her body right
she's she's then choosing to change her
whole body whatever whatever happened
like she's gonna have to go through all
those changes off her body it's her
choice whether she wants to go through
that or not that that feature doesn't
have feelings it can't think of anything
until okay until it's viable of course
24 weeks
an abortion changes your body too like
you can make it so you don't have kids
later yeah but that's if you had it
depends but that's one of the risks of
abortion doesn't happen with every
single abortion that's a risk where do
you think the life cycle starts yeah
that's what I wouldn't know yeah where
do you think the life cycle start what
point yeah well I'm Muslim so 120 days
so your life cycle only starts at 120
days
120 days while it's like from conception
so it doesn't start as soon as sperm
hits egg that's not when a life cycle
starts for you no that's like a Cell
It's like a cell that you can pick up
your life it actually is a unique DNA
code that's different from the mother
and the fathers in 98 of biologists say
that life begins at conception but if
we're gonna believe like the science you
know they say life begins at conception
right but it's not it's not it's not
wait who says Life Begins 90 of
biologists 90 of biologists say that
life begins at conception yeah like if
they found um like if they found
a unique DNA code on Mars like everyone
would be freaking out like wow that's
crazy I have a solution for this
if uh fair enough you wanna you wanna
board the child your body your choice
but if the man doesn't want to board the
child who doesn't want you to board the
child I feel like you should still have
the right to do so but you need to give
the father a payout you need to buy him
out
I just think abortion should have two
people's signature on a piece of paper
saying that we both choose to abort this
child yeah that's what that's what I
personally believe I believe that if not
if I I believe that it's not just a
mother's choice because like I said the
father started that life cycle too so he
should have a say and the only way our
child should be aboard if is if both
parents agree to it I don't think the
woman having all of the Soul power over
uh the child which is a man's that
you're going to as soon as it comes out
to him saying look this is yours child
support like he doesn't it's like he
doesn't have any rights until that child
leaves your womb and then as soon as he
leaves your womb the woman has the power
to just control that man's life I don't
I don't think that's fair and as a man
if you're if you're killing my child
like I need a payout for that you know
like how much would the payout be
foreign
upwards like it has to be an
astronomical amount so that would that
would stop women from getting abortioned
I have a question so you're saying
life's so valuable and women should not
be allowed to abort it but it's
negligible when it comes to money
involved no no I'm saying women should
be alive because you can't force a woman
to do something that they don't want to
do with their body but you have to not
you have to take in account the fact
that the man also has an investment
there emotional they sacrifice as well
as women you know if not not with their
body but with their with their mental
health with their like their with their
like they provide and whatever like
imagine 18 years of providing for a
child right if the the man doesn't want
to have a kid
like who's paying the man
for those 18 years where he lost the
child that he could have had
how does the how does the man get
you know
that's heartbreaking
depends what type of man you are really
some men have no emotions because they
were raised with no emotions so if they
get a woman pregnant she didn't see you
later have a good day thank you as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible